[Música]
es un gran placer estar con ustedes aquí
para presentarles esta edición de canadá
en las américas café y bueno encantado
de estar con ustedes y muchísimas
gracias por su alta fidelidad hoy con
leonora chapman paloma martínez y
leonardo que bueno les presentamos
canadá en las amenazas de este viernes
26 de abril en vivo y en directo por
facebook live youtube en nuestro sitio
de internet
rcn punto sea y en nuestra aplicación de
la cual le vamos a hablar un poquito más
tarde leonora leonardo paloma bienvenido
igualmente
sí porque efectivamente después de todos
los años de 75 años creo que tenemos 27
bueno no siempre lo mismo no pero de
éxito
internacional a lo mejor si tenemos el
principio yo creo que hay gente que nos
escucha desde hace muchísimo tiempo de
los años 60 que dijeron antes entonces
pues estábamos muy contentos de estar
aquí con ustedes y
bueno vamos a comenzar este programa de
canadá en las américas café de este
viernes con alguna nota insólita o una
noticia que les haya llamado la atención
y leonora vamos a comenzar contigo a ti
te interesó este ataque terrorista que
se llevó a cabo en sidi la ncaa
me llamó la atención este atentado no
sólo por lo brutal que fue y 359
están revisando las cifras pero también
porque fue dirigido contra los
cristianos en tiempos de paz cuando
entonces se aprovecharon que la gente
estaba en tres iglesias fueron atacadas
simultáneamente no sé si lo podemos ver
un poco las las imágenes
fueron atacadas simultáneamente y
entonces lo que me llamó la atención es
que un experto canadiense decía de que
estamos todos acostumbrados a escuchar
hablar de islamofobia estamos muy
acostumbrados a hablar de ataques contra
judíos pero este ataque pleno plenamente
fue dirigido contra los cristianos y fue
digamos llevado a cabo por una otra
minoría que son los islamistas y esto
fue en sí lanka decir si blanca tiene 70
por ciento de la población que tiene la
religión de religión no no no no budista
budista es la mayor la mayoría
extremadamente pacíficas no
necesariamente significa menos
[Música]
santana las minorías ryong ya se llama
de la lógica llamarla ellos los que
atacan son ellos entonces
y finalmente lo que quiero decir es que
el 70% de ellos es una religión la que
nombramos pero hay dos grandes minorías
que son los musulmanes y son los hindús
y los cristianos son la minoría más
minoría y finalmente son una minoría que
atacó a otra minoría entonces eso me
llamo rezo los islamistas que están
atacando pues hace cierto tiempo por
todos lados en el medio claro pero no
son los únicos que atacan y los
cristianos no son las únicas víctimas
nada más que ahora creo que ninguna
religión se salva en ninguna parte del
mundo hay una persecución religiosa lo
que dicen los que lo están diciendo el
ser y la ncaa que estos estos ataques
que fueron llevados a cabo a raíz de
como venganza a raíz de los ataques que
se llevaron a cabo en nueva zelandia
entonces es una cosa que no tiene ni
principio ni fin
y mientras tanto deja estragos civiles y
sobre todo civiles muertos en todas
partes entonces fue un té fue un ataque
muy muy feroz muy duro
muy brutal bueno y tú paloma entre las
curiosidades te interesó un pueblo de
muñecas tamaño natural muñecas y muñecos
muñecos ese en japón no es aquí en
canadá pero me hizo pensar en un
fenómeno que es muy canadiense también
que es el éxodo está mucha gente yéndose
de los pequeños pueblos en japón y en
canadá también para irse a las grandes
ciudades y en japón en particular me
llamó la atención porque una persona una
mujer que le gusta mucho coser y bordar
se puso a hacer muñecas niños niñas
señores señoras de todas edades en
realidad de tamaño natural y las fue
poniendo en todos los lugares donde ya
casi no hay gente porque este pueblo
queda de por sí pequeño solo tenía
alrededor de 300 o 400 personas en su
auge digamos pero ahora sólo quedan como
35 personas y ya no hay niños ni jóvenes
entonces ella llenó la escuela
de los niños donde está donde haya hubo
niños de puras muñecas de hechas por
ella misma tenemos imágenes de las
muñecas de japón y están pues poblando
el pueblo finalmente que está viviendo
este éxodo masivo y que en realidad lo
viven también otros lugares de canadá
también en el mundo en general pero en
canadá también se vive esto este tipo de
situaciones en las que los jóvenes se
van buscando mejores oportunidades
digamos que es lo contrario de lo que
sucedió por ejemplo aquí en canadá
recuerdo por allá en los setentas que la
gente se iba al campo y eso le llamaban
aquí el regreso a la tierra y entonces
la gente se era el éxodo de la ciudad
hacia el campo en búsqueda de una vida
más tranquila en búsqueda de
tranquilidad de naturaleza no entonces
este caso de lo mira la escuela entonces
el éxodo pero del campo hacia las
ciudades es el regreso a la ciudad
mundanalrüido y yo creo que existe ese
fenómeno de irse de las de los pueblos y
de las ciudades pequeñas hacia las
grandes ciudades en todo el mundo
internacional la gente está buscando
deben vivir mejor entonces y encuentran
que los empleos pues están en las
ciudades pues lo mismo sucedió ahí en a
goro en japonés me pareció bonito a un
camino tiempo es triste porque
finalmente va a terminar por morir
simplemente ese pueblo porque si quedan
sólo 35 personas quedarán muy bien
cuidado no no hay servicios no hay
absolutamente nada y bueno pues se le va
a tocar y van a quedar al mudarse a
otros jueces sobre las muñecas del abono
acá dijo pueblo había un pueblo también
no no me acuerdo en que incluso si eran
alberta que había quedado prácticamente
vacío y había un señor que ofrecía su
granja que se la regalaba a quien
quisiera venir al lugar y hacerse caso
de los animales de cultivar la tierra
por esto no
entonces si a ese fenómeno yo creo que
es mundial es que antiguamente no hace
tanto tiempo de hecho la estas tierras
cultivables pues se trata me van
permitiendo de padre a hijo eran los
hijos los que se encargaban de asegurar
el relevo pero ahora pues ellos también
se están desplazando y yéndose a otros
lugares entonces con esta agricultura
agresiva que se está desarrollando en
todas partes con las maquinarias y eso
tras otro tipo de explotación agrícola
también donde ya no caben los pequeños
agricultores entonces tampoco pueden
sobrevivir no ahora creo que también hay
una como decía pablo también hay un
movimiento de vuelta a las a las tierras
porque se están dando cuenta que a
medida que los cambios climáticos van
avanzando iban llegando impacto digamos
impactando las ciudades y las zonas y lo
vamos a ver en el momento dado con las
inundaciones de las que ha sido víctima
montón de gente aquí en quebec en
ontario también entonces la gente está
viviendo los impactos reales en sus
vidas lo están volviendo a son
más alejadas de donde está toda la gente
para crear como nuevas comunidades yo vi
que hay un proyecto que estuvo está
siendo difundido por los medios de
comunicación aquí en canadá es eso de un
programa de televisión en lo que van a
crear una especie de comuna
autosuficiente entonces ahí todo todo
todo lo que se come lo que se produce es
para la gente que vive ahí entonces
quieren crear eventualmente ciudades o
pequeños pueblos que sean
autosuficientes y que puedan vivir
justamente sin nada del exterior vamos a
ver si es posible hay libros escritos
sobre la autarquía como pues ellos
pueden al menos intentar sobrevivir pero
wang los únicos que lo están haciendo
creo a nivel organizacional es ya son
son comunidades grandes son las
comunidades religiosas como las que los
que viven en manitoba en otros lugares
del mundo en paraguay en mil
que si son autosuficientes pero son un
futuro en el mar no dicen que es el
futuro porque si no no más sobre no
tenemos por ahí algún fantástico primero
fantástico en todos los sentidos tú
tienes efemérides y además de eso nos
vas a hablar de tanos que es un
personaje de la última película de los
súper héroes de la noche noche a noche
ya tengo comentarios si así dicen que es
como bueno en realidad hay muchos
actores que le habían dicho durante
último durante la filmación quedan o
volvían así que los bolsillos empiezan a
sandro
en este caso
han lanzado esta nueva película que es
en game que se supone que es el final la
conclusión de la película
empezamos con mi familia
[Risas]
es mejorando tanto en los efectos como
en el contenido de los logos exacto así
que bueno en este caso la última
película que fue infinity world fue la
la guerra el infinito no hay un el malo
en el personaje más los demás tan osos
sanos este h
y en este caso google ha hecho como una
especie de doodle que es este festejo
que hace google con ciertas cosas en su
sitio en tener entonces cuando uno pone
en el google y busca la palabra sanos
que es el nombre del malo aparece la
página con todos los resultados la
última película de infinity world la
anterior a ésta que está ahora en
cartelera sanos juntaba seis piedras que
le daban todo el poder del universo y
hacía y la gente volaba de trabajo y la
mitad
el 50 por ciento de la humanidad desea
viajar
bueno entonces google lo que ha hecho
para festejar esta película ha hecho
este todo el consell con sonidos y puede
ser cosa
cuando uno hace clic en la pequeña mano
que se ve a la derecha arriba uno hace
clic en la mano y no se escucha pero
empieza a desaparecer el contenido que
desaparecía en la película el 50% de la
gente
excelente con monos ya estabas ahí no
hay que hacerlo de nuevo ok
y los personajes mueren en esta peli no
sabemos lo que queremos saber y lo
interesante de esto es que cuando uno
pone en un computador en el ipad se ve
con esta forma reducida pero el
computador muestra la cantidad de
resultados que son como 90 y cuando uno
pone sanos son como 96 millones
resultados y después de que desaparece
quedan 46 42
gracias al de tanos así que bueno esto
[Risas]
es más no poder y después bueno este año
este mes
el 23 de agosto en realidad esta semana
estamos adelantando demasiado
la otra película de abril abril el 23 de
abril se cumplen 14 años se cumplieron
primer vídeo de youtube el primera lista
la primera historia que estuvo alojado
en el año 14
ahora es el segundo motor de búsqueda
más importante
no se hacía pero si tienen relaciones
cosas que la gente la gente busca lo que
busca es dígame cómo se hace tal cosa
creo que busques así que bueno la otra
esta semana perdón pero arreglamos la
lavadora de atrás
de vajilla de mi casa con vídeos de
youtube
técnico yo conozco una persona que
aprendió a hacer electricidad los cables
todo esto es extraordinario cuando se le
pierde el mapita de cómo armar un mueble
de esta conocida marca
lo busque está como armarlo está puesto
en un vídeo bueno y esta semana también
también el 23 de abril no agosto el día
mundial del libro y del
del derecho de autor derecho de derechos
de autor desde la y después el 28 se
adentró el 28 en dos días y se festeja
el día del quad san andreas a mitad de
precio los procesados por el caso podría
ser un que tenía siete ir viajando y
conociendo montreal a través de su padre
porque además es que el croissant ya no
es sólo el corazón así natural
viene con al mes
lo que busques
sin piedad y por último bueno en
realidad lo tenemos y la semana que
viene pues estamos diciendo lo que
pasaron el día del animal es el 29 así
que nosotros animal humano si nosotros
en ese orden
[Risas]
gracias
yo tengo una nota un poco más distinta
pero igual de simpática y sucedió en
manitoba donde unos padres de familia de
niñas que practican el nado sincronizado
padres de familias decidieron ellos de
organizar el primer equipo masculino
sincronizado entonces ya el nado
sincronizado no es sólo un deporte
femenino sino que estos padres de
familia que son 11 en total han decidido
formar el equipo y están con ellos la
idea
de recaudar de recaudar fondos
aquí están entonces ellos se van a
recaudar fondos para este club acuática
5 de winnipeg donde estudian las niñas y
los geniales
este club festeja sus pares en el equipo
y de alentar también a los chicos a
practicar
muy de acuerdo porque siempre me
pregunté por qué los hombres lo hacen
esos como los chicles de cheerleaders
la mujer no tiene los hombres porque son
las que cargan no pero no son los que
hacen las acrobacias generales a las
mujeres que hacen esto
son igual de acróbatas sí y entonces
pues ellos tienen una entrenadora del
mismo club de las niñas que los está
entrenando todo esto con el objetivo de
hacer un espectáculo en público en la
piscina panamá de winnipeg el 25 de mayo
próximo que es el día del décimo
aniversario de ese club acuático esto se
me pareció esta idea de estos señores
muy aficionados y medio locos porque es
una idea completamente loca pero se les
veía muy serio se lo toman enseñar
pero pensé que era de broma que me
pareció muy simpático algo que menos
simpático que está sucediendo en este
momento aquí en la provincia de québec
son las inundaciones y en ontario las
inundaciones en ontario
acaba de declarar el estado se han
mandado 400 militares ya están en
camiones es muy seria la cosa sí y
tenemos algunas imágenes de las
inundaciones
y aquí en quebec una de las regiones que
más se ha y vemos a personas voluntarios
que están llenando bolsas de arena
aunque es una forma de armar diques
alrededor de las casas y a veces también
los situadas para largo mira para ir a
la escuela los niños tienen que ir en
canoa me hace pensar aún una cuento de
un autor colombiano de la costa
colombiana que escribió ese cuento que
se llama porque me llevas al hospital en
canoa papá si entonces me hacía pensar
este a ver los chicos y en canoa para ir
a la escuela es una tragedia es una
tragedia hamburguesa y ya está hay
muchísimos evacuados hay gente que se
resiste a la evacuación en lo que estaba
diciendo también ingenieros de hydro
québec y otros funcionarios canadienses
que están tratando de empujar a la gente
a que salgan de sus hogares y se resiste
en la localidad de riego que está
a cerca de aquí de montreal la
evacuación hoy era obligatoria y esta
mañana viene una imagen aérea de lugares
increíbles en solamente los techos y
salía un entrevistado una persona que
vive ha comentado que decía que este año
hay 50 más de 50 centímetros de agua
y lo que están las previsiones para hoy
son tremendas porque va a llover todo el
viernes y el sábado
hablan de 40 50 milímetros de agua de
lluvia más la nieve que todavía hay
muchísima nieve que se está definida
entonces la conjunción de esos dos
fenómenos va a ser que los niveles de
agua se eleve ahora lo que es particular
es que no es un fenómeno nuevo parece
que cada vez que tenemos hacen estas
inundaciones estamos sorprendidos y
vemos la amplitud pero estuve escuchando
en la mañana un reportaje con archivos
de 50 de 50 años también y
de más de 50 años porque de los años 40
se creó los archivos más antiguos que
encontraron aquí en radio canadá y
resulta que es lo mismo que se repite
cada cierto tiempo y que tienen que
evacuar a la gente y que les dicen no
vendan esos terrenos que están cerca del
de los de las riberas porque si no cómo
y por qué se continúan inundando y ahora
lo particular ya de lo que se está
hablando con respecto a estas
inundaciones es que no es sólo el
deshielo lo que provoca eso sino todo
este cambio climático que está
sucediendo un poco por todos lados en el
mundo y que contribuye a estas
cantidades de agua también increíble que
tienen inundado varios pueblos acá
así es eventos que antes no llovía tanto
como está lloviendo ahora hay más
precipitaciones ni tenían llevando tanto
recuerden que tuvimos 10 centímetros de
nieve a principios de abril generalmente
en abril hay un poco de nieve pero se
derrite rápidamente y ahora se quedó se
acumuló y ahora se está derritiendo
así es entonces pues me parecía una idea
tuya para la vista de pasar esas
imágenes de hablar de las inundaciones
que están azotando de alguna forma la
provincia de québec yo no hay algún
comentario en realidad yo lo quería ver
en el line que tenemos conectado y
justamente como estamos conectados ahora
no los veo así que subieran el teléfono
a la vieja usanza y ahí está nuestra
emisión dice el vídeo en directo cuando
pongo ver el vídeo desde ese sitio no sé
por qué no sabes pero comentarios hay y
en este caso es javier gonzález nuclear
hay que dice a lu2 a todos como siempre
bien preparado para exponer los temas
que presenta el programa felicidades
leonardo nicolás manuel reyna los
terminados desean razón de ser real san
ramón de la nueva orán o en salta
argentina miriam alarcón me dicen cómo
hago para recibir dice una notificación
cada vez que también tienen vivo en
realidad media en facebook en facebook
de la opción y nosotros lo hacemos la
misión en vivo todos los viernes
a las 1330 salvo ese 15 salvo en
ocasiones especiales y ocasiones
especiales como por ejemplo a partir del
mes de agosto
pero salvo situaciones especiales como
por ejemplo si llega a haber alguna
emisión especial desde el salón de
cultura como hemos hecho en estación que
va a haber por ahí cambia el horario y
el día pero es siempre los viernes salvo
contraindicación pero le vamos a indicar
la notificación o lo vas a ver después
dice realmente extraordinario en youtube
que bueno ese festejo qué rico y saludos
cordiales a todo el equipo profesional
de comunicadores desde quiport mayor si
es rené betancourt
miriam dice que tristeza lo de las
inundaciones aquí en la provincia de
tucumán
en el cambio climático consecuencia del
mercantilismo es la causa sin dudas
bueno entonces voy a aprovechar para
decirles a todos los que nos están
escuchando en este momento de que pueden
hacer pequeños vídeos y nos los pueden
enviar nosotros los vamos a pasar aquí
en este programa como el que le vamos a
pasar ahora de la del nuevo edificio de
la nueva sede de radio canadá que es un
pequeñito vídeo esto es en la esquina de
para pino y de la nieve ahí vemos la
casa de vidrio la casa de cristal en la
nueva sede de radio canadá nos están
construyendo a ser habilitada el primero
de enero del año próximo tenemos ganas
si estaba viendo una estaba viendo un
mensaje por ahí que decía que los
trabajos están avanzando a muy buen
ritmo y que al primero de principios el
primero de enero salud el primero de
enero ya tendríamos que entrar este es
otro vídeo también es de la misma
esquina pero la mano izquierda el otro
ángulo otro ángulo entonces es
simplemente para decirle a nuestros a
nuestros oyentes que pueden hacer
pequeños vídeos en ese estilo cortos de
su ciudad de su barrio de algún parque
en fin que nos muestren ellos nosotros
vamos a seguir este mismo estilo
mostrándoles aquí en montreal
este vídeo vemos el antiguo
de ese edificio grande está atrás ahí
estamos en este momento de duración de
los vídeos
bueno mira este dura como 40 segundos
más o menos yo creo que un 30 entre 30
segundos y un minuto
estaría correcto si entonces los
invitamos muy cordialmente a que nos
hagan conocer sus lugares cómo son esos
lugares que me los imagino ya muy
bonitos
[Música]
son vídeos
bueno y ya que estamos haciendo de los
vídeos o vídeos entonces
yo creo que quizá valga la pena
recordarles la aplicación de la
medicación ente ya que tenemos un
público cautivo
miren ahí tenemos ese es el videíto de
presentación de nuestra aplicación donde
bueno muestra a grandes rasgos cómo
funciona la aplicación en ese caso ahí
estamos haciendo un paneo por primero de
aplicaciones en francés inglés ahora
estamos en español después viene
el árabe y el chino son las cinco
lenguas en las que está disponible esta
aplicación son aplicaciones separadas
pero la aplicación en español por
ejemplo tiene la posibilidad entrar a la
iglesia francés si uno quisiera por
ejemplo porque aparte no es que el sitio
en francés y el sitio en inglés hacen
las mismas noticias hay cosas que son
muy distintos de cada una de las lenguas
entonces por ahí vale la pena ir a
consultar el contenido en otra lengua y
las árabes y chinas son muy diferentes y
lo que les voy a mostrar es a partir de
la ipad
como ir a hacer para bajar la aplicación
por lo menos
en el sistema operativo de apple así
podemos ver en pantalla ahí está esta es
nuestra pagina rcn punto o sea aquí a la
derecha arriba tienen en la publicidad
que dice aplicación móvil uno hace clic
ahí en aplicación móvil
el sistema
ahí uno entra a esta es la página de la
aplicación estamos aquí en la página
aplicación y entramos a donde dice
disponible en apple store un clic en
apple store y dice abrir a productor
entonces abre la tienda de todo lo que
haga productos autos apple y ahí está
nuestra nuestra aplicación en realidad
aquí dice abrir porque nosotros ya la
tenemos bajada en este ipad entonces
cuando le abrimos esto es más o menos lo
que se ve en un ipad qué
me pidió autorizaciones y ahí está estos
son los contenidos como se ven dentro de
una aplicación
es muy diferente porque solamente de uno
solamente se ve como si fueran estás
tico como si fuera no se puede como si
fuera una sola noticia hacia abajo y en
este caso si uno pone ahí y se va hasta
nuestros programas en vídeo qué es lo
que acaba de hacer clic ahí está canadá
las américas café estamos ahí en vivo
a ver si nos vamos a ver en realidad
estoy hablando de es como como estoy
hablando a mí mismo pero después me está
comunicación entonces excelente así de
que los invitamos también a todos
ustedes a visitar a hugo a experimentar
esta aplicación de radio canal
internacional y bueno pues esperamos que
les guste tanto como nos gusta a
nosotros aquí en este estudio y en
leonora para el viernes próximo y esto
es también para todos ustedes que están
allá porque ya van a ver como los vamos
a implicar quinientas noticias
vamos a tener invitados aquí en el
estudio y esto es en el marco de el
festival literario metrópolis blue
island metrópolis o metrópolis entonces
hay dos autores hispano canadienses que
van a estar aquí con nosotros y ellos
vienen a presentar una antología de la
cual participaron 25 escritores hispanos
canadienses que se titula historias de
montreal es el segundo volumen que
lanzan el primero fue historias de
toronto hace dos años que tuvo muchísimo
éxito en su lanzamiento en toronto
primero en montreal después esta vez es
a la inversa el lanzamiento es en
montreal y ellos vienen pues como
dijiste en el marco de este festival
volvemos el sitio del metrópolis blues
ajá entonces se trata de josé antonio
villalobos él es un peruano canadiense
escritor que viene acompañado él vive en
toronto y viene acompañado de germán
rodríguez que es un salvadoreño de la
ciudad de calgary ambos
canadiense en la provincia de alberta
entonces son 25 los autores dos de ellos
van a estar aquí el próximo viernes y la
idea fue finalmente fue un oyente
nuestro creo que de colombiano rodrigo
proceso está por ahí porque yo hice una
entrevista con josé antonio villalobos y
entonces puse el libro la tapa del libro
de historias de montreal y él dijo
porque nos regalan un libro nosotros ni
cortos ni perezosos pues yo le escribí a
jose antonio y posibles no creo que diga
que no así que es casi seguro vamos a
tener un libro el próximo viernes como
hacemos es otra historia pero que vamos
a sortear que vamos a sortear y aquí es
donde ustedes están implicados los vamos
a sortear aquí en directo se va a hacer
una pregunta que todavía no sabemos
nuestro cuál es muy difícil pero que
pero que la van a conocer el próximo
viernes cuando estemos aquí en el aire
le vamos a hacer al inicio del programa
y al final del programa en la que hemos
estado antes
primero que conteste a la pregunta
y lo esperamos a las siete de la tarde
para que lo vengan a buscar a corto
lapso pero vamos a hacer no pero al
menos no le podemos mandar el pasaje
pero si después
así si el pasaje todo lo que recuerdo es
que alguna vez
uno de nuestros oyentes de hecho omar
ortiz
bogotá que había ido a china porque
radio china internacional sorteaban
pasajes para ir hasta china y hubo
varios de nuestros oyentes que ganaron
pasajes para visitar china pues
desafortunadamente pues para nosotros
nunca existió nunca existió
- y nuestros tiempos
alarcón desde ahora pero lo voy a
olvidar con contreras rincón también
desde barranquilla colombia y miriam
dice que nos va a mandar un vídeo
es hermoso el edificio que mostrábamos
recién
tenemos una cita así que otro que nos
manda es nelson rincón como decía pablo
saludos desde barranquilla colombia y
juan josé nos dice wow que están súper
gracias juan jose si todo el no hay más
arriba de los trabajos o los que salimos
ok entonces a nelson aprovecho para
decir tener sonia que está por ahí algún
videito de barranquilla 30 a 45 segundos
un minuto lo que tú creas que es más
chévere presentar de barranquilla y lo
mismo para todas las otras personas que
nos están escuchando un videito de de su
ciudad y lo pasamos aquí está muy bien
continuamos entonces y el tiempo se nos
fue
nos dimos cuenta
entonces pues entonces vamos a los temas
de hoy
leonora tú nos hablas del proyecto
mujeres en todas las letras sí y este
libro lo presente justamente el día del
libro este reportaje entrevista el 23
que fue el día del libro acá en el mundo
es una entrevista con mabel gonzález
ella es directora ejecutiva vamos a ver
de que ella es colombiana vive aquí en
montreal conversando un poco con ella me
contó que a los 15 años se dio cuenta
que le quedaba chica su colombia donde
ella vivía el pueblo y a los 20 se
recibió de abogada se fue a vivir a
españa se fue a vivir a alemania anduvo
por todo el mundo iba y venía a colombia
y finalmente se enamoró de un canadiense
y se vino acá a montreal a la isla y
entonces en línea con su hermana mabel
que es mabel vive en colombia ellas han
creado y fundaron mujeres con todas las
letras con un sitio internet es un sitio
internet mujeres con todas las letras
donde ellas quieren
buscan visualizar dice el aporte
femenino al desarrollo del centro y
sudamérica y ofrecen a niñas y niños
referentes y modelos diciendo entre
otras cosas que los sueños no tienen ni
género ni límites y array y en ese marco
sacaron este libro que se llama mujeres
con todas las letras a ese set de aceta
y son pues las 20 son la historia de 28
mujeres que marcaron a su manera la
historia de diferentes países de américa
latina no se trata sólo de nombrar a la
mujer sino además es un pretexto para ir
al país y ver qué es ese país y lo que
ellas hicieron entonces tenemos mujeres
de hansen ahí por ejemplo estamos viendo
la imagen que está pasando que es
rigoberta menchú bolivia es preciosa a
mí me encanta las ilustraciones que
tienen su libro inclusivas de mano al
tema la razón
entonces tenemos y son estas historias
de las 28 mujeres son cinco niñas
que van paseándose por 28 por esas 28
letras y van mostrando las diferentes
mujeres que uno va encontrando al paso y
finalmente yo me dije que es un libro
que a mí me interesa en leerlo porque me
doy cuenta que hay muchas mujeres que no
conozco que hicieron grandes cosas en
américa latina está chavela vargas y a
la venta van a ver las imágenes son
preciosas y esa por ejemplo hay una que
se destacan una gran científica
colombiana que yo no tenía idea y que es
ángela restrepo entonces la misma no sé
no me gusta me exceden justamente
entonces este este esta producción de
este libro en realidad se hizo con
varias personas en diferentes lugares
del mundo hay una una en chile hay otra
mujer en eeuu de ella en canadá otra en
colombia y trabajaron en línea para
encontrar estos personajes y este es el
resultado este libro que me parece que
es una buena idea para regalar a niños y
niñas y adultos y pueden visitar nuestro
sitio internet
rcn punto ósea y escuchar la entrevista
la autora que es mabel s abel gonzález
gonzález muy bien paloma martínez unos
hablas de un proyecto de realidad
virtual que es muy particular y muy
inéditos y me parece maravillosa la
utilización que hicieron estos artistas
porque son artistas martín hazle que
anik daño de la realidad virtual porque
ellas son madres de niños autistas y son
especialistas de las imágenes y de los
sonidos y decidieron meterse en el mundo
de la realidad virtual y explorarlo para
que la gente pudiera descubrir qué es
cómo ve un niño autista el mundo porque
una de las particularidades del autismo
de ciertos tipos de autismo porque hay
tantos autismo como personas como ellos
lo dicen es la hipersensibilidad a los
sonidos a las imágenes entonces que
hicieron que la gente que se pone el
casco de realidad virtual pueda
imaginarse la vida de un niño autista y
en el vídeo que les presentamos ahí en
el reportaje
si podemos ver
exactamente si pues ya nos hemos play en
el vídeo podemos ver las imágenes de la
de la del niño viendo el mundo entonces
se ve como los colores son impactantes
como los sonidos pueden ser impactantes
también y es como meterse en la cabeza
de un niño autista y descubrir por qué a
veces los niños autistas se sienten
invadidos digamos por todo lo que los
rodea entonces me pareció maravilloso
como proyecto entonces el niño se llama
machis es un es un personaje ficticio
es ficticio pero lo crearon a partir de
es un proceso documental entonces fueron
a recuperar información con sus hijos
exactamente y con eso y con otras
personas no solamente sus hijos y
entonces crearon digamos recrearon la
visión de un niño autista pero el
autismo es una realidad
ineludible en toda la sociedad
exactamente entonces por eso quieren que
la gente los conozca mejor como lo viven
muy bien antes de que se me olvide los
controles técnicos hoy ven un gran marc
andré de sant y tierra
leonardo gimeno tu nos hablas de la
adicción al teléfono inteligente y cómo
contrarrestarla
yo no sé si ustedes dieron cuenta de
ordizia propósito durante todo él no me
hiciste caso estuviste nuevas mira que
lo hice a propósito para mostrarles de
qué se trata la adicción al teléfono
cuando uno pone el teléfono aquí ya
estás poniendo una barrera con la gente
porque está diciendo si pasa ahora estoy
listo para cortar la comunicación y leer
el teléfono te lo hice para que ustedes
me llama la atención ella él se dio
cuenta me llamó la atención dos o tres
veces y es porque está ahí y uno lo pone
bueno en este caso
el director ejecutivo de apple que a
partir de una noticia que decía que el
papá francisco he dicho en una reunión
con alumnos de un colegio secundario
diciendo que el teléfono era uno de los
grandes problemas al día de hoy que
había que sacarse del teléfono para
poder vivir una vida más plena para
poder conversar para poder vivir la vida
en realidad entonces el director
ejecutivo de apple dijo si el papá tiene
razón y así es como yo hice no lo que él
hizo justamente fue dice el primer paso
no significa que no use el teléfono no
significa que no lo vea constantemente
pero lo que hago es desconectar no
deshabilitar las notificaciones eso ya
es un paso grandísimo hay un promedio de
que la gente normal mira aproximadamente
dos mil 617 veces el teléfono por día
para las notificaciones notificaciones
notificaciones notificaciones entonces
todo el contenido de esta investigación
está ahí la puedan ver junto o sea y muy
rápidamente ya nos queda muy poco tiempo
yo hice una entrevista esta semana con a
lucky luke y ccu ctic que es la
presidenta de una asociación inuit de
defensa de los derechos de los inuit que
se llama tunga tunga vic y ella se
presentó esta semana juntamente en el
foro permanente de naciones unidas sobre
las cuestiones indígenas para presentar
un informe sobre la lengua y la
educación en una voz y el título del
informe es la educación en un agua en
una voz criminalmente inadecuada los
autores van hasta decir que se comete un
crimen contra la humanidad ella nos dice
rápidamente que hay 25 comunidades en
una bud 43 escuelas 42 enseñan en inglés
en francés y ninguna en actitud entonces
quiere decir que privar a los niños y
nuits de la educación en multitud es un
crimen contra la humanidad muy
interesante la entrevista con ella así
que los invitamos a visitar nuestro
sitio internet y eso fue todo para este
canadá en las américas café aquí de este
viernes
leonora leonardo gimeno paloma martínez
hasta la próxima
[Música]